Jacky
merci Cheb Bilal
nous continuons
regarde tous les télégrammes qu'on a
reçu depuis le début de l'émission pour
te demander de chanter encore
très bien la bossa nova tu aimes la
bossa nova j'aime la bossa nova alors on
va chanter la bossa nova OK
Google
les garçons la regardent
et
leurs idées qui bavardent
des regards qui
s'attardent sur le corps de la fille aux
yeux clairs mais elle ne voit que la mer
merci
il n'a pas de quoi
merci dire
Idir j'ai une question que je voulais je
voulais vous poser je pense qu'elle est
toujours actuelle c'est le rapport à
l'Algérie c'est c'est le la distance qui
existe toujours avec ce pays et la
distance qui existe surtout dans votre
mémoire avec ce pays
en fait il y a pas de distance parce que
c'est mon pays je suis encore algérien
de nationalité
j'essaye
des fois sans illusion mais souvent sans
réserve d'établir des passerelles des
pentes ces deux rives de la Méditerranée
que nous vivons comme ça sur toile de
fond de de
non-indifférence il y a toujours des
relations de passionnelles basées sur
des l'amour ou sur des de la haine les
jardins différentes donc j'essaye de
mieux que je peux d'établir des
passerelles entre ces deux pays que
j'aime profondément question sur sur le
DVD qui sort actuellement et qui vous
concerne entre scène et terre pourquoi
avoir choisi ce titre quels sont les
scènes quelles sont les terres
l'État c'est là où on était aimé on est
accueilli parce qu'on est un peu
toujours de là où on aime et on était
même les scènes parce que j'estime que
la vérité de notre métier est dans le
spectacle vivant en général tout se
passe en temps réel on est devant un
public qui souvent n'est pas dupe donc
ça passe ou ça ne passe pas et cette
vérité nous apprend à être nous-mêmes
déjà et nous oblige aussi à donner le
meilleur de nous-mêmes aux autres
merci
je vous présente le chanteur il est
aussi auteur compositeur percussionniste
qui va suivre il s'appelle manuel Wang J
et il a au moins une qualité c'est qu'il
déteste la façon dont en France ont
qualifie ou on enferme dans des cases la
musique africaine voilà manuel vanji
Malka trip Malka le nom de la compagnie
c'est Malka trip c'est tripes et ça veut
dire délire manuel one J